today I'm going to ask my co-workers
what's something you haven't told your
mom oh there's a lot of things I haven't
told my
Mom I have a tattoo
stuff I've done in
that I've had sex
you think some emergency I took her
purse that she likes and I didn't give
it back so if I've done in a lot of
different countries I snuck out of the
house one time when I was like 14 and I
went out the window and I ran down the
street got immediately scared that you
were gonna find me and then went right
back in I don't know I tell her
everything I broke the base when I was
younger and I blamed it on my twin
brother I don't think she knows that
I've done drugs that I miss spending
time with her every day since I moved
out I haven't told her that I'm coming
to see her this weekend my sister's
starting to get better than her cooking
I have a surprise for her for Mother's
Day I'm taking her to her to a spa I'm
gay
[Music]